GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON.
.
IN RESPECT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CHAIR WILL
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED AS A
SUB COMMITTEE EVEN THOUGH WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM.
UNLESS THERE'S ANY OBJECTIONS
TO THAT ON WE COULD GET STARTED
AS A FULL YOU KNOW. FULL
COMMITTEE IF YOU LIKE BUT WHEN
WE GOT JUST ARTIST SUBCOMMITTEE
BRIEFLY IN THEM. WILL ALLOW THE
PRESENTATION TO BEGIN SO MUSEUM
ON WHICH LIKED TO BEGIN. THINK
YOU. AND I THINK YOU AND VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT FOR
HAVING YOU HERE. ON JANUARY
FOURTH THAT THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HIS PLANS TO EXPLORE
THE OPENING OF OUR COSTA
OFFSHORE DRILLING ON JANUARY
FIFTH I IN THE JOINT AUTHORS IN
THIS RESOLUTION. A FORMALLY
ANNOUNCED OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS
PLAN.
THIS BIPARTISAN BILL ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION EXPRESSES THE
LEGISLATURE STRONG AND
UNEQUIVOCAL OPPOSITION TO THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION'S DRAFT
PLANNED TO OPEN ALL THREE
REGIONS OF THE CAL RECENT SANTA
BARBARA FOOD HERE
OIL SPILL. MY COMMUNITY HAS PAID
THE PRICE.
THESE BILLS DISSEMINATE TOURISM
ECONOMIES.
ECOSYSTEMS AND ANIMALS.
TO PUT THE THREAT IN PERSPECTIVE
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL OCEAN
ECONOMIC PROGRAM.
NATIONAL OCEAN ECONOMIC PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA'S COAST WERE ECONOMY
EMPLOYEES FIFTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE GENERATING
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT ONE
TRILLION AND CREATES AN
ESTIMATED EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND VISITORS ENJOY
THE STATE'S OCEAN AND COAST FOR
RECREATION EXPLORATION. TOURISM
AND COLLECTIVELY THEY COMPROMISE
THE LARGEST SECTOR OF THE
STATE'S.
OCEAN ECONOMY.
THE THREAT AND REALITY OF CAT
EXTRA
CATASTROPHIC SPILLS EXPLAINS WHY
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT IS SO
STRONG IN MY DISTRICT AND ALL
COSTA REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH ALL PISSED THREE PACIFIC
COAST GOVERNOR'S UNITED IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL THE
LEGISLATURE WILL JOIN A GROWING
MULTITUDE OF VOICES SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST THIS PROPOSAL.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME MANDATES
ACT MANDY SACKETT FROM THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION AND DAN
JACOBSON WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK ON SUPPORT
OF THIS AJ ARE.
OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON.
TEAR ACOSTA. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MANY SECOND
ON THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
COORDINATOR FOR THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION. OUR MISSION IS TO
PROTECT THE WORLD'S OCEAN WAVES
AND BEACHES I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
NINE.
THE RESOLUTION WOULD AFFIRM THE
STATE LEGISLATURES STRONG AN
UNEQUIVOCAL SUPPORT FOR THE
CURRENT FEDERAL PROHIBITION OF
OFF NEW OFFSHORE DRILLING GAS.
SORRY OIL THAT OIL AND GAS
DRILLING IN FEDERAL WATERS OFF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN
WAVES AND BEACHES ARE VITAL
RECREATIONAL TREASURES OF THE
POLLUTED BY AN INCREASE IN
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING. HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS COME TO OUR BEACHES
EACH YEAR AND GENERATE NEARLY
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS AND
COLLECTIVELY RECREATION
EXPLORATION AND TOURISM. COMPILE
THE LARGEST SECTOR OF THE
STATE'S FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLAR
OCEAN ECONOMY.
AFTER OIL HAS CONSISTENTLY LED
TO OIL SPILLS DESTROYING BEACHES
AND COASTAL COMMUNITIES DRIVING
RESTAURANTS SURF SHOPS CHARTER
BOATS AND OTHER TOURISM BASED
INDUSTRIES OUT OF BUSINESS.
IN FACT THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA OPPOSE
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
OIL SPILLS ARE AN INEVITABLE
INEVITABLE PART OF OIL DRILLING.
WE ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THE
RESOLUTION TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP SO CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S RECREATIONAL
ECONOMIC AND ECOLOGICAL
WELLBEING.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DAN JACOBSON WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA I MAKE THREE QUICK
POINTS. FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND ALL OF
HER CO AUTHORS FOR TAKING A
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE ESPECIALLY IS
UNITED STATES DECIDES WHAT KIND
OF AN ENERGY FUTURE THAT WE
WANT.
SECOND THING ON NOTE IS THE
POLLING RESULTS FROM THE PP I
SEE SURVEY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THAT INDICATED A
RECORD LOW TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA ADULTS. FAVORED
MORE OIL DRILLING OFF THE COAST
WHILE A RECORD HIGH SIXTY NINE
PERCENT OPPOSED IT.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE CONSISTENT
ACROSS PARTY ACROSS PARTS OF THE
STATE'S ACROSS.
GENDER EXETER X. CENTER UP SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE RESOLUTION THAT
YOU'RE DOING. THIRD I THINK THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT.
THERE ARE ENERGY SOURCES OFF
THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO TAP INTO BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ENERGY SOURCES THAT WE WOULD
HAVE IS.
THEY'RE CLEAN WIND THAT BLOWS
OFF THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA THIS
IS A REALLY VITAL RESOURCE THAT
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING TO TAP
INTO.
IT CAN PROVIDE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF GOOD PAYING JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND.
IT'S REALLY ONE OF THE BEST
ENERGY SOURCES THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE IT BLOWS WHEN CALIFORNIA
NEEDS THE ENERGY THE MOST IN THE
LATE AFTERNOON AND EARLY
EVENING.
SO FOR THAT IN A PREVIOUS
REASONS IT WAS STATED WE WOULD.
AND COURAGE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS RESOLUTION AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE SOCIAL.
WELL AS WE DON'T HAVE A CHAIR I
I THINK I LIKE NEVER BECOME ON
UP.
TO THE MICROPHONE THAT IS SET
IN SUPPORT AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL
DO OPPOSITION OR NOT. FIRST AWAY
ON THE CHAIR SO.
WELL ABOVE ITS I JUST BE
RESPECTFUL OF TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON KYLE JOHNSON
CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORTERS
LESION THANK YOU.
HI ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NIKITA KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
HELLO DOT NYC LOFT IN ON BEHALF
OF THE OCEAN.
CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT THINK
YOU.
HELLO MARTA ALVAREZ ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAY THE OCEAN
CONSERVATION THE OCEAN
FOUNDATION AND CALIFORNIA
COASTAL PROTECTION NETWORK WE
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
IT LOOKED LIKE IT.
OKAY
I NEED.
COMMENTS FROM THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WITH THE RESOLUTION.
WORK WE HAVE YET WE HAVE INTENT
THE STEPS QUORUM YET.
.
RIGHT OR
I THINK WE SHOULD PROBABLY DO
THAT I'VE HEARD FROM THE CHAIR.
OSCILLOSCOPE AND AND WRAP IT UP
BUT WILL ALLOW WILL ALLOW
OBVIOUSLY COMMENTS AFTERWARDS
LISTA LET'S TAKE ROTH THANK.
MEMBERS GARCIA ACOSTA HERE
ACOSTA HERE ALLEN. ALLEN HERE
CHAU CHOW HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE FLORIDA.
LIMON HERE LIMON HERE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MITSUBISHI. MITSUKI
HERE STONE SHOWN HERE.
OKAY NIKAU QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE HAD ALL WEEK.
WE WANT TO HADN'T RESTATE YOUR.
MOTION AND SECOND JUST FOR THE
RECORD. MOVED TO ADOPT
RESOLUTION.
REAGAN
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY.
I MAKE A COMMENT I'M SORRY
BILLIONS.
AS WELL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
US.
I THINK WE HAVE I SPENT QUITE A
BIT TIME THIS WEEKEND WITH A LOT
OF COASTAL ADVOCATES VERY VERY
CONCERNED.
ABOUT DRILLING OFF OF OUR COATS
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THAT THE
HISTORY OF.
FEDERAL LEASING USUALLY WHEN
THEY ASK FOR.
LEASING PROPOSALS IN VARIOUS
SECTORS ALONG THE COAST IT'S
BEEN TARGETED ITS BAN THOUGHTFUL
IT'S BEEN DIRECTED IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING WE HAVE FIVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT IF IT IF
THEY'RE TALKING BACK CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE FACT THAT THE MISTRESS
CAME UP AND JUST LIKE IT SAID
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP ALL LEASING.
REALLY MAKES WILL.
THE QUESTION THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING OR WHAT THEY WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH.
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER.
THREE DECADES ESTABLISHED THAT
WE WOULD NOT BE EXPANDING
DRILLING IN.
OFF THE SHORES OF CALIFORNIA AND
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING THEY'RE CLOSING DOWN
OIL PLATFORMS THERE AND LIFE IN
CERTAIN OIL FIELDS.
THEY REALLY WINDING DOWN THAT
DRILLING BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN A PARTNER.
THE CALIFORNIA'S LONG
ESTABLISHED STANCE OF NO
INCREASE IN OIL DRILLING OFF OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEN THE SHOWS.
AND I LAUD ALL OF THE PROTESTS
MARCHES.
CIVIC ACTION THAT HAPPENED OVER
THE WEEKEND TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT THIS
CHANGE IN PERSPECTIVE IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
WELCOME HERE.
THE RISKS ARE SIGNIFICANT WERE
MOVING FORWARD WITH TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE ADAPT OUR
OCEANS TO THE CHANGING CHEMISTRY
TO THE CHANGES THAT WERE SAYING.
AND ADDING TO THAT THEY EIGHT
AND EXACERBATED THREAD OF OIL
SPILL AND OTHER CONTAMINATION
REALLY PUTS AT RISK THE.
TWENTY THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR
COASTAL ECONOMY THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT UP OVER THIS TIME.
SO IT JUST SEEMS.
HARD TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
BEING ATTEMPTED OR WHAT IS.
WHAT THEY THINK THAT THE END
GOAL THOUGH THE PROCESS IS GOING
TO BE? SO I THINK IT'S VERY PORT
FOR ALL OF US AND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS STEP UP NOW AND SAY
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
ACCEPTABLE AND.
MAYBE THEY'LL LOOK ELSEWHERE OR.
BILL BUT MORE THOUGHTFUL IN HOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS EVEN
IN THEIR TERMS.
THE NATION'S ENERGY NEEDS BUT
THIS IS INAPPROPRIATE FOR US NOW
HAS BEEN INAPPROPRIATE FOR THREE
DECADES AND IT'S GONNA BE A
FIGHT THAT WE WILL CONTINUE SO I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND YOU DO REPRESENT AN
AREA THAT IS MOST THAT THREAT.
BECAUSE YOU THINK EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE
IT'S REALLY HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
IF LEASES WERE GRANTED OFF OF
OTHER WATERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THEY WOULD WOULD EVER BE ABLE
PUTTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
ABLE TO MATCH THAT OIL BUT IN
YOUR AREA. IN YOUR DISTRICT
OFTEN HANNAH BARBARA THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE EXISTS OF THE
THREAT IS. FAR MORE TANGIBLE AND
FAR MORE RIO SO IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD AND HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE.
IS WILLING TO SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE HERE AS ARE THE
LEGISLATURE'S OF OREGON AND
WASHINGTON ALSO SET.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING.
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE.
WELL. I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD.
YEAH I WANNA SEE ALSO DOESN'T IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS.
KNOWING TO NOT CONTINUE MORE
BUT THAT. HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY
HERE'S GONNA VOTE FOR THIS
BECAUSE WHAT'S COSTING TAXPAYERS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO CLEAN UP
ESPECIALLY. ON COMPANIES THAT
HAVE WHERE LEASES THEY'VE GONE
BANKRUPT A AND IT'S A MESS AT
THE TAXPAYERS GET STUCK WITH OUT
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS PAIN FOR
CLEANUP A OF THE OF THE BAND IN
A. THINGS AGAIN I MUST MUCH LIKE
A LOT OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
DECISIONS WERE MADE WITH GOLD
KNOWLEDGE NOW WE HAVE NEW
KNOWLEDGE AND SO WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND ACCORDINGLY WITH
POLICY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MCCARTY THANK YOU I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT THIS AND CERTAINLY I
KNOW OUR COASTAL DELEGATION
MISLI MON MISTER STONE'S TO
CHIU.
GLORIA MARTZ RICHIE AND WOOD
REPRESENT THE BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT A NATURAL NO BRAINER BUT FOR
THEM SOME OF US WHO ARE NINETY
MILES AWAY. WE STILL LOVE OUR
COAST TO.
AND IT'S GREAT TO BE ABLE TO GO
DOWN. AT TO THE COAST NOT TOO
FAR FROM HERE AND NOT JUST FOR
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES WHICH
YOU WENT ABOUT THAT THE THE
OBVIOUS BUT JUST TO ENJOY.
MOTHER NATURE YOU KNOW YESTERDAY
WE HAD THE SUPERBOWL OUR LITTLE
GIRLS ARE TRYING OUT FOR THAT
NATURE BALL.
AND IMMIGRANT.
APPARENT BEHIND US ARE HERE FROM
THE SAME SCHOOL AND THEY TALK
ABOUT THE CUTS.
AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO FOCUS ON MAKES SURE THAT WE.
ENJOY A I MOTHER NATURE AND.
YOU KNOW.
THAT THE OIL SPILL YOU SPOKE
ABOUT IN SIXTY NINE WHILE PEOPLE
DON'T REMEMBER PEOPLE REMEMBER
THE EXXON VALDEZ MAYBE IN. A
NIGHT THINK IT WAS THAT WE HAD A
RECENT ONE. DOWN YOUR NECK OF
THE WOODS.
A FEW YEARS AGO AND WE KNOW THE
DANGERS AND AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THIS IS THAT
WE NEED TO SEND OUR
CONGRESSIONAL. DELEGATION A
MESSAGE THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT
FROM A BIPARTISAN LEVEL. WE SAW
THE PRESIDENT TOOK FLORIDA OFF
THE OFF THE.
PROPOSAL LISTS AND WISE
CALIFORNIA A DIFFERENT INDEED WE
KNOW THE ANSWER BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SEND. A
MESSAGE TO OUR OUR LEADERS IN
INTO DC THIS IMPORT FOR OUR
ENTIRE STATE.
I WAS GONNA SPEAK BUT THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH TALK OFF FROM COAST
REPRESENTS I FELT THAT
HUNTINGTON BEACH SHOULD WAY AND.
I AS A COSTA REPRESENTED THE
REPRESENTS NORTH COAST ORANGE
COUNTY ORANGE ARE OF THE NORTH
BOT COASTAL PORTION OF ORANGE
COUNTY. IN HISTORIC OIL TOWN
HUNTINGTON BEACH
I FEEL THAT WHO IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT WE
ARE THE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE.
AND THE COAST DOES NOT JUST
BELONG TO CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE OR ONE POLITICAL
PARTY.
CALIFORNIA'S MORE OIL AND GAS
THAN SAUDI ARABIA WITH TODAY'S
DRILLING EXTRACTION TECHNIQUES
WE CAN NOW EXTRACT OIL AND GAS
SAFER AND MORE CLEANLY THAN EVER
BEFORE. IN THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA HAS VAST RESOURCES
THAT MUST BE USED FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR ENTIRE STATE WHEN
WE IMPORT OVER I BELIEVE IT'S
CURRENTLY SEVENTY PERCENT. OF
OUR ENERGY RESOURCES FROM OTHER
AREAS OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
EXPORTING OUR DOLLARS WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO EXTRACT OUR
RESOURCES THAT BELONG TO
CALIFORNIANS.
NOT JUST THE POLITICIANS OF
SICKNESS CHAIR BUT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THE THIRTY NINE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND THE ABILITY TO DO
THIS CLEANLY SAFE WHEN
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY. WE
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY DO THAT AND
MAXIMIZE THE VALUE FOR EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT I WILL BE VOTING NO
ON THIS AND I SINCERELY HOPE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
STRIKE CALIFORNIA OFF ITS LISTS
MATTER FACT I SINCERELY HOPE.
THAT THE PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION COMES TO
CALIFORNIA ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN MAXIMIZE NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR THE BENEFIT EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIAN. AND AT THE
SAME TIME OF COURSE DO THIS
CLEANLY SAFELY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
IT'S MY DECISION.
YES I'D LIKE TO.
JOIN MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES IN
THANKING THE.
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
BIPARTISAN.
PORT FOR OPPOSING OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING.
AS EVIDENCED IN MY OWN DISTRICT
IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN HERMOSA
BEACH.
THREE YEARS AGO THERE WAS A
PROPOSAL TO.
RENEW OIL DRILLING.
AND IN THIS COASTAL COMMUNITY.
AND.
THE OPPOSITION TO THAT LOCAL
INITIATIVE WAS OVER EIGHTY
PERCENT.
AND WHAT THAT EIGHTY PERCENT.
CLEARLY INDICATES WAS THAT IT
WAS NOT JUST DEMOCRATS
BUT IT WAS ALSO REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS
WHO OPPOSED.
OIL DRILLING THAT THREATEN
THEIR COSTA COMMUNITY.
THE NEIGHBORING MANHATTAN CITY
OF MANHATTAN BEACH ALSO STRONGLY
OPPOSED THIS OIL DRILLING
PROPOSAL THAT THREATEN NOT JUST.
THOSE TO BEAT CITIES IN MY
DISTRICT BUT THE ENTIRE SANTA
MONICA BAY SO I THINK THE
EVIDENCE FROM RECENT. VOTES
TAKEN IN MY COMMUNITY IS A CLEAR
EXAMPLE THAT WHETHER A DEMOCRAT
OR REPUBLICAN.
WE DON'T WANT OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING IN CALIFORNIA.
MR KAUFMAN GO AHEAD.
.
THANK YOU.
FOR MEMBERS LAMONT FOR BRINGING
US THIS FOR.
I THINK ABOUT ONE OF MOST
TROUBLING THINGS FOR ME IN THIS
PARTICULAR.
BILL ALTHOUGH I THINK WE NEED
TO KEEP OPTIONS OPEN.
I AM REALLY TROUBLED BY THE FACT
THAT THE BILL I'M SORRY WITH
EUROPE WE ARE OUTLINING THE
BILL.
IS THE PROPOSAL IS TO IS ANY
ROLLBACK AND SAFETY REGULATIONS
I DON'T THINK IT GIVEN ALL THE
TESTIMONY AND COMMENTS WE'VE HAD
TODAY. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
PRUDENT SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL I THE SENATE
RESOLUTION TODAY.
DO WE HAVE ANY MORE COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISS LIMO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
SURE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE DISCUSSION AND.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT AS SOMEONE WHO WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT AND THIS VOICE IS NOT
A LONE VOICE.
SIXTY NINE PERCENT OF PEOPLE
SURVEYED IN A STUDY DONE LAST
YEAR BAY PP I SEE AGREE THAT
EXPANDING OFFSHORE OIL IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA. STILL BY NO MEANS IS
THIS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL I THINK
THAT RIGHT NOW WE ARE INVITING
WHAT CALIFORNIA WANTS TO DO AND
WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH A LARGE
THRESHOLD. OF CALIFORNIANS ON
BOTH SIDES ON ALL SIDES WHO SAY
THIS IS NOT THE DIRECTION Y.
MOVE FORWARD I THINK IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
BE THAT VOICE. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE COLORFUL.
ITEM ONE AJ ARE TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON THE MOTION
IS THAT THE MEASURE BE ADOPTED.
MEMBERS GARCIA.
AYE GARCIA AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA
AYE ALLEN.
ALAN NO CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
LIMON. AYE LEMOYNE AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MERTZ ITCHY. RUSTICI
AYE STONE. STONE AYE.
EIGHT ONE.
EIGHT TWO ONE THAT THE MOTIONS
OUT THANK YOU